hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
Rezept mit Zwetschgen
eigentlich hatte ich ja überlegt dass
wir einen
Zwetschgendatschi machen hoppla habe ich
schon auf dem Kanal dann dachte ich mir
hey mach doch ein Zwetschgen Hefekuchen
habe ich schon auf dem Kanal dann habe
ich mir gedacht mach doch
Zwetschgenkuchen mit Quark-Öl-Teig habe
ich auch schon auf dem Kanal dann habe
ich mir gedacht mit Streusel habe ich
auf dem Kanal ohne Streusel habe ich
auch schon auf dem Kanal was gibt's denn
jetzt noch für ein Rezept mit Zwetschgen
was ich noch nicht auf meinem Kanal habe
und dann fiel uns ein gallett eine
Galette eine Galette ist was richtig
genial ist es nämlich so eine Art
Mürbeteig ähnelt aber eher dem
amerikanischen Teig also ein Teig ohne
Zucker und dann ist die Zubereitung mega
einfach die Zwetschgen kommen rein es
kommt noch zum Zucker drauf und
karamellisiert das im Ofen und es ist so
wahnsinnig lecker dass mir jetzt schon
der Magen knurrt und ich werde später
ihr könnt mit Eis servieren ihr könnt
dazu sagen ihr könnt Vanillesoße oder
einfach pur essen warm und kalt schmeckt
gut und eine Galette ihr solltet auf
jeden Fall mal in eurem Leben eine Gale
zubereitet haben deswegen gibt's hier
die Zutaten ich brauche ungefähr 220
Gramm Mehl etwas Salz 140g eiskalte
Butter ein Eigelb und 5 Esslöffel
eiskaltes Wasser ihr macht es jetzt so
am besten verwendet ihr einen Mixer
falls ihr keinen Mixer habt geht aber
zum Beispiel auch ein Teig Zerhacker
wichtig ist nämlich und deswegen betone
ich auch eiskalt die Butter muss eiskalt
sein gerne kurz ins Gefrierfach stellen
das Wasser eiskalt auch gerne kurz ins
Gefrierfach und dann ist es einfach so
dass der nicht lange geknetet wird das
heißt ich gebe jetzt das Mehl mit dem
Salz hier in den Mixer verrühre das
Ganze kurz die Butter kommt dazu und
dann wird es einfach nur so pulsierend
gemixt damit die Butter noch in kleinen
Stückchen zu sehen ist am Ende kommt
dann noch das Eigelb dazu mit dem Wasser
und es wird nur so lange verarbeitet bis
die Masse ungefähr so ein bisschen
zerdrückbar ist
fertig
er sieht nicht fertig aus aber ist
jetzt hier auf eure Arbeitsplatte
bzw Silikonmatte auf der Rolle ich das
auch später aus
und es sieht einfach falsch und bröselig
aus aber es ist gold richtig
jetzt einfach nur die Hände nehmen und
leicht zusammendrücken
und der Teig darf nicht warm werden
damit die Butter einfach nicht schmilzt
und warm wird denn später geht es im
Ofen so ein bisschen auf wie so eine ja
wie so ein Blätterteig dann wird das so
ganz ganz wunderbar blättrig knusprig
also jetzt hier auf dem Teller geben
flachdrücken
abdecken und ab mit dir in den
Kühlschrank für ungefähr eine Stunde
könnt ihr auch gerne am Tag noch
vorzubereiten ist gut vorzubereiten ihr
könnt auch so ein Teig vorbereiten und
einfrieren und habt immer gallette Teig
auch vor Ort ist auch immer nicht
schlecht
wolltest du weiterhin weil der
Kühlschrank normalerweise weiter Weg
direkt hinter mir ist und hat mich
erfreut darüber was zu trinken gesehen
habe nämlich einen
zeige ich euch noch online
ja lecker ist es
[Musik]
der Teig schön abgekühlt und ich kann
ihn hier auf der Arbeitsfläche ein
bisschen ausrollen
auch wenn ich jetzt schon ein paar Tage
hier arbeite ist das doch schon immer
noch sehr ungewohnt in der anderen Küche
egal
hier auch wieder nicht so sehr kneten
der Teig will nicht so sehr geknetet
werden
und hat auch so eine ganz eigene
besondere Konsistenz wie so ein paar
Teig einfach
und jetzt ausrollen etwa 5 mm dick
das muss jetzt auch kein perfekter Kreis
sein ich finde das sieht sogar schöner
aus wenn er nicht so perfekt ist
den Rand aber gerne so ein bisschen
dünner
also da streiche ich hier einfach noch
mal entlang
und setzt den Teig dann direkt um
auf mein Backblech
so doch nicht perfekt aber genauso
aussehen
jetzt habe ich hier schon meine
Zwetschgen
Zwetschgen sind jetzt zum Backen perfekt
geeignet denn der Stein löst sich leicht
und sie haben einfach nicht so viel
Flüssigkeit wie Pflaumen z.B und ist
eigentlich so der große Unterschied
Pflaumen sind die runden sind die langen
und aus Pflaumen macht man gerne Kompott
oder kocht sie ein und Zwetschgen sind
so die die man einfach zum Backen
benutzt die habe ich jetzt halbiert und
geviertelt den Stein rausgenommen und
die könnte jetzt einfach direkt hier auf
den Teig geben in die Mitte
[Musik]
teilen und hier schön den Rand lassen
und hier habe ich jetzt noch etwas
Zucker und Zimt das passt nämlich
geschmacklich einfach perfekt die
Zwetschgen sind so ein bisschen
säuerlich haben aber eine leichte Süße
und je nachdem wie süß ist bei euch sein
soll gebt ihr jetzt einfach Zucker dazu
das sind jetzt so knapp 50 Gramm müsste
aber auch nicht komplett nehmen und dann
karamellisiert das ein bisschen an der
Oberfläche und
schon ich rieche jetzt schon wie es
schmeckt schmeckt ziemlich gut hallo
ich finde sie so lustig weil einfach
immer irgendwo irgendwann durchläuft und
ist einfach so lustig ist egal
eigentlich müssten nur hier direkt
durchlaufen aber witzig wenn sie aus dem
Schrank kommt hallo
jedenfalls habe ich jetzt den Zucker
drauf und klappt jetzt hier die Seiten
rein aber offen sollte es trotzdem
bleiben also da oben
schön einpacken
dann den Rand bisschen mit Eiweiß
bestreichen und gehobelte Mandeln drüber
streuen und dann kann die gerles schon
in den Backofen und am besten serviert
ihr sie einfach direkt heiß mit
Vanillepudding mit Vanillesoße mit Eis
oder einfach pur ich liebe sie auch pur
wirklich sehr und ihr könnt hierfür
wirklich alles Steinobst verwenden ihr
könnt eine apfelett machen Nektarinen
Aprikosen Quitten
apfelkürbis und ich finde das passt
einfach alles was euch schmeckt alles
was so leicht säuerlich ist aber eben
auch diese besondere Süße hat
das Wasser
[Musik]
an den Rand karamellisiert auch schön ab
mit denen den Backofen
[Musik]
guck mal seht ihr das ist meine ich mit
dem Teig der wie so ein Blätterteig ist
der hat so Schichten
und dann blättert er so
gut und das ist mit Streuselkuchen mit
Hefeteig mit Quark-Öl-Teig die schönste
und beste Art Zwetschgen zu genießen
okay und Zwetschgen aber so die vier
fünf Rezepte die solltet ihr einfach mal
ausprobieren und diese Galette auf jeden
Fall auch ich hoffe ich jetzt nicht
immer schön Eis zu essen oder kurz
abkühlen lassen nee ich meine
Puderzucker
so süßer Schnee das passt perfekt egal
ich es ist so ich mag es eh nicht ganz
so süß und ihr probiert das Rezept
wirklich unbedingt mal aus und schreibt
mir auch gerne ob ihr Zwetschgen mögt ob
Zwetschgen auch wie bei mir zu euren
Leibspeisen gehören und ob ihr diese
Galette ausprobieren werdet
bestreut aber ein bisschen mit
Puderzucker kleines bisschen ich hätte
einfach den ganzen Zucker nehmen sollen
wie es im Rezept steht wie ich es euch
ins Rezept geschrieben habe so stimmt
gut
macht's gut bis zum nächsten mal das
Rezept gibt's auch.de und in meiner App
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
ab und zu sind Kommentare auch nicht
schlecht muss ich ehrlich sagen so ein
bisschen Feedback ist schon immer ganz
gut
ja
[Musik]